self-driving cars aren't just here
they're everywhere
they're still in testing sure but this
technology is on its way it's just a
matter of when and where it will land
first and when that happens robot cars
will likely change society as we know it
just as the personal automobile did a
century ago people have dreamed of
owning a self-driving car for
generations but until recently it seemed
impossible so I always thought
autonomous vehicles would happen to be
honest I didn't think I'd see it in my
lifetime the idea of a driverless car
became a lot more real about a decade
ago that's when a group of Engineers and
roboticist gathered for an unprecedented
competition called the DARPA urban
challenge this is absolutely astounding
each team brought something unique to
the table from breakthroughs in
artificial intelligence to advanced
laser sensors to well let's just call it
public relations
it was the moonshot of the robotics
world without the challenge idea there
would just not be a surviving car today
the task looked incredibly hard you had
to be the calm of a drive itself without
a person inside I think the Grand
Challenges proved to the world that it
was possible
when we think of autonomous cars today
it's Tesla Google and uber that come to
mind but the industry wasn't born in
Silicon Valley or even Detroit it came
from here of all places
in the early 2000s Congress decided to
invest in driverless vehicles not so
that we could commute to work while
checking Facebook but to keep soldiers
safer on the battlefield
and they tapped the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency aka DARPA to
make it happen that's the same agency
that helped create the predator drone
and Agent Orange along with GPS and the
Internet so in 2004 the US government
held a new kind of competition to
jumpstart the industry the DARPA Grand
Challenge it was the first of three
races that would help make self-driving
cars a reality before the DARPA Grand
Challenge the US government had spent
hundreds of millions of dollars trying
to build self-driving cars and lo and
behold most of this money didn't give
the expected results instead of funding
its usual stable of defense contractors
DARPA decided to open the problem up to
anyone interested in cracking it it
would hold a race across the Mojave
Desert for 100% driverless cars with a
million-dollar prize for whoever
finished fastest the response was
enormous teams applied from all over the
country representing universities high
schools and groups of friends with a
taste for engineering DARPA didn't have
any preconditions for participation
right like anybody could show up and you
saw everybody show up it felt like it
was anybody's game but from the
beginning the Grand Challenge had a
front-runner Carnegie Mellon University
home to the nation's oldest and most
prestigious robotics Institute and also
to William Redd Whitaker a former Marine
who sent robots into hazardous
environments like nuclear reactors and
volcanoes it isn't enough just to do the
technology and hide it in a laboratory
it real
matter to take it to the world on the
day of the challenge in March 2004 the
15 finalists teams gathered in the
desert north east of Los Angeles they
would start five minutes apart each
following a GPS route that would take
them 142 miles from Barstow California
to prim Nevada first out of the gate was
Carnegie Mellon's sandstorm and 1986
Humvee with the roof chopped off and the
seats ripped out in their place was a
half-ton box stuffed with computers to
give sandstorm an edge the team
collected satellite imagery to figure
out the fastest safest route across the
desert sandstorm put the hammer down you
could really see the punch at that point
that dust was blind and it was heading
to the finish line but most teams
struggled just to get out of the
starting area out of the gate spirit
came out took a left was looking at the
gate ahead to the right and decided that
it was too narrow or there was something
going on and so it took a u-turn and we
didn't make it very far and we had to
turn it off at about 20 or 30 feet
meanwhile Kannagi melon's sandstorm was
racing ahead until it hit a series of
hairpin turns
known as daggit ridge and that's where
damage from a crash during testing a few
weeks earlier came back to home boom
the sensors misread the road and the
Humvee got stuck so it just does fundin
smoke did that until the race officials
at the end of the first challenge the
dream of self-driving cars still seemed
out of reach when we didn't have a
finisher that was a hard time the way
people look at challenges is if someone
finishes that was a success and if they
don't it was a failure I mean for the
scientists among us that's just another
data point but people want to see
somebody get through to the end we're
better or worse everybody struggled that
first Grand Challenge
see him you got the farthest they went
you know almost eight miles and the rest
of the teams did pretty poorly so so we
were in good company
what dhaba had done was create a
community of people eager to crack the
self-driving car problem so the agency
announced it would give them another
shot at the 2005 Grand Challenge the
Grand Challenge was a very unique
environment it was kind of nerdy kind of
geeky you know and it was it was also
kind of sports event see as one team
that had a surfboard on the car because
the guy running it was a surfer dude we
were kind of a gimmicky team sort of by
design you know having the surfboards
and we had some models come out to sort
of draw people to some major events this
time they'd be asked to drive 132 miles
in a series of loops around the Nevada
desert the teams had the experience of
the first grand challenge to build off
and the year and a half to get it right
many of the original players jumped
right back in the announcement was let's
go again see in eighteen months and
we'll double the money well that's a
no-brainer it became a lot more real it
seemed like something was really on the
line for the second one for the o-5 race
Carnegie Mellon would play the odds by
running two Humvees but the competition
was stiff a slew of newcomers dove in
foremost amongst them a German computer
scientist named Sebastian that a robot
has to make all the decisions so I
attended the very first Grand Challenge
as a spectator
and the best performing vehicle did
about 7.3 miles before it went up in
flames there were some vehicles that
would make it 100 yards and then get
completely confused or flip over and to
me as a roboticist I felt I could do
better than this
his team at Stanford University decided
to rely on what was then a relatively
new technique called machine learning
our secret ingredient was AI it was
machine learning B we actually trained
the robot to do the right thing we
trained in how to die it speed with a
steering wheel and so on all these
essential things we believe that the car
trained to perform better than a car
instructed conventional so even when our
with our car and trained it to drive on
the right Road and that training gave us
that I think I had a winning edge as the
2005 race got underway Carnegie Mellon
and Stanford were neck-and-neck then
halfway through Carnegie Mellon's
Highlander slowed just like sandstorm a
year earlier it had crashed about a week
before the race this time damaging a
component that modulated power going to
the engine the CMU team hadn't caught
the problem and once again their
frontrunner was crippled my first
reaction is well that's it of course
it's never your last rodeo you got to
get on with things
team Stanford pulled ahead and crossed
the finish line first 19 months after a
disappointing first go-round DARPA
finally had a winner someone had found
two big buckets of ice water and poured
them out of our lake and me they just
felt on my gods it's the biggest day of
my life
but the defense agency wasn't quite done
with self-driving cars the teams had
conquered the desert now the dream of a
self-driving car in every garage was
getting closer the only way to really
test the technology was to set them
loose in a city the biggest efficiency
of the dapper Gwynn challenge was that
it was a static race even other cars nor
kids running around or bicycles it
wasn't real traffic you know the most
disruptive the most crazy idea would be
the whole urban area full of robots
running and not crashing into each other
they said if we could just create that
picture somehow and show it to the world
the world would look at this and say you
know although I thought it was kind of a
stupid idea but it looks like it you
know this could be real
the vehicles were nowhere near safe for
public roads so they settled on an
abandoned Air Force Base in Victorville
California for the third race the DARPA
urban challenge the teams that braved
the races in the desert geared up for a
whole new kind of battlefield instead of
kicking up dirt they'd be navigating
intersections obeying stop signs and
executing three-point turns gone were
the Humvees and June buggies of the
desert challenges in that place 10 cars
that looked almost normal Toyota Priuses
and Ford escapes all of them decked out
in sensors and stuffed with computers
machine learning had proven itself in
the desert but to make it work in a city
the cars needed better machine vision in
the first challenge of Silicon Valley
engineer named Dave Hall used cameras to
let his robotic Toyota Tundra see its
surroundings as he prepped for the
second race he heard about a different
approach called lidar a radar like
device that uses laser beams instead of
radio waves to map its surroundings a
lot of it came from talking to the guys
at the first race and one of the
conversation that they had with Jim
McBride at Ford and he said this lidar
is is really unusual eyes tool many of
the challenge teams have been using
primitive laser sensors that could spot
opticals ahead but with little context
and limited resolution Hall invented his
own version of later that saw in 3d and
offered ten times the detail of the
lidar that came before it so if you
imagine if you just get sixty four laser
pointers and stack them up and draw them
across and out those are the beams that
I'm scanning across whatever those laser
beams hit or what I'm measuring and if
the laser beam didn't hit anything you
absolutely knew the road was clear he
made it spin and stuck it on the roof of
his car and he wasn't alone in the O 7
challenge nearly every top team used
holes lidar system the robots now had
the vision they needed to see the world
clearly but they still had to figure out
how to navigate it
on the day of the DARPA urban challenge
the finalists rolled out of the starting
gate and into a new world of difficulty
each had six hours to accomplish three
missions a mix of intersections tight
turns and even last-minute route changes
and they had to do it without hitting
the human driven Ford Tauruses the other
robots or breaking the California
traffic laws Carnegie Mellon's vehicle
boss push those laws to the limit it's
racing and you know boss had a little
reputation for being aggressive but it
had the unimpeachable reputation of
being smart and handling everything that
had to be handled comfortably
some teams had more trouble MIT and
Cornell smacked into each other other
robots locked themselves into a traffic
jam but for the most part the race
itself was as exciting as watching cars
drive around a suburb that is to say
they nailed it six teams finished the
whole course so congratulations to red
wicker and his team they come across the
line now after three challenges red
Whittaker and Carnegie Mellon finally
had come in first the trophies were nice
but it was about more than prize money
the men and women who brought the DARPA
challenges to life could now see a more
valuable reward making self-driving cars
a reality Dabra Grand Challenge brought
together a community of people they
might and paper be competitors but we
were as eager to share our deepest
technological secrets with other teams
to have other teams members would go
from garage garage and talk to the guys
who were running the other vehicles so
there was a tremendous amount of the
information sharing that took place that
was probably the most important part of
the whole challenge the participants
went on to form the backbone of the
self-driving car industry when Sebastian
Thrun started Google's self-driving car
project in 2009 he knew exactly where to
look for help
I hired the best people I could find and
guess who mired i herded technological
heads of our competing things other than
challenge Dave Hall turned his company
valo dine into a leader in the now
booming lidar industry and read
Whittaker continued his work at Carnegie
Mellon building robots and training the
next generation of engineers the future
is in very good hands that potentially I
think everybody sees today in 2017 is
goes orbit to the dollar gunshot as the
DARPA Grand Challenge model courage and
the double album challenge none of this
would have happened right now but the
industry has at least one Grand
Challenge left convincing the public
that it's time to let the robots take
the wheel